you do your business flush the toilet
and in theory give your hands a good
wash the problem is too many people are
taking shortcuts research in hospital
toilets has showed just what's being
strutted around including fecal matter
and dangerous bacteria people just sort
of thing well just join hands and a
story but actually that's not the case
most of us wash our hands not perfectly
the folks are still there so when you
dry them in the jet air dryer droplets
are squatted into the environment onto
the machine onto the floor onto you into
the air but paper towels are said to
absorb the water and microbes instead
and the study carried out in three
hospitals revealed that bacterial
contamination was significantly higher
on the day's hand dryers were used
instead of the disposable tissue we may
not be in a laboratory but by doing a
simple experiment using this bulb and
some liquid which glows we should be
able to see just how far germs can
potentially spread you can see just how
far along the wall when it's spread
pretty unsurprisingly it's also dripped
down inside the dryer bag it's not good
if those splashes are contaminated by
microbes some of the germs that could
pass around include a coli and there are
different strains of E coli some are
classified as toxigenic and if someone
was to ingest those then it could lead
to a rapidly deteriorating situation
that could even cause a fatality so you
should take about 20 to 30 seconds to
wash your hands hand dryer manufacturers
point out the problem is in the washing
not the drying of the hands and that the
research has been funded by the paper
towel industry there's also the fact
that you
needs to be disposed of it doesn't help
the world in such a rush so you wash
your hands and then stick them under the
dryer quickly and then actually take
them away before the dried property
because actually you know it's a bit of
a bore standing in to live properly dry
and then you kind of rub them on your
jeans the problem is you can't see what
lurks within the droplets of water only
by washing thoroughly every time we'll
germs be stopped in their tracks
em'ly virtually stai news